two days into the e3 excitement and it's
finally the first day of e3 there's been
no shortage of news so let's jump right
into today's roundup brought to you by
Qualcomm Snapdragon LTE modems for
epically fast LTE speeds
it was a good day for Zelda fans after
years of anticipation Nintendo finally
blew the lid off the new Zelda that will
release on the Wii U as well as
nintendo's next console codenamed the NX
The Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
is an open world adventure in which link
can jump climb tame wild horses and
forage the environment for resources but
Zelda isn't the only thing Nintendo
showed off today Pokemon Sun and Moon
got a brand-new trailer and announced a
new free for all battle mode we also got
further details on games featured
earlier this week Ubisoft confirmed that
you can complete watchdogs to without
killing anybody and the new god of war
game is officially set after the events
of god of war 3 and will not feature an
open-world finally if you've got two
hundred dollars burning a hole in your
pocket Microsoft is hoping you'll spend
it on this Gears of War for branded
elite controller III is in full swing
and there's plenty more news previews
and impressions on the way so be sure to
stick with gamespot com to stay up to
date on the latest in the biggest gaming
event of the year
you